Blastoise games and books we talk about
what a complete home theater more of a
success of the force awakens is the more
of a success that the merchandising will
be really have no time for anything else
if you didn't know that a new Star Wars
film is coming out in December 2015
then you may be living in a galaxy far
far away after all the new film is
everywhere with new toys on shelves
movie trailers online and even
Campbell's soup cans in your local
supermarket but this merchandising is
nothing new for Star Wars in fact it's
just the latest example of how the
original film franchise revolutionised
filmmaking and changed the weight
Hollywood movies make money I was always
able to see it as more than just a movie
I came in at first through the back of a
cereal box instead of at the theatre
that was when I first first learned the
story of Star Wars that's Chris Taylor
and he's the author of the book how Star
Wars conquered the universe the past
present and future of a multi-billion
dollar franchise the total dollar amount
through the movies through the prequels
the books that are made the toys is
there like an actual dollar amount that
we could say this is how much Star Wars
has made yes the best estimate that we
have based on the numbers they're
already out there from you know what was
a privately held company in lucasville
is roughly in the region of forty two
billion dollars forty two billion and
thirty two billion of that is from
merchandising large sized dog daily
you had Kenna which was making money
hand over fist with the toys I'm not
just the action figures with all sorts
of toys blasters board games the factors
t-shirt company back in 1977 that
produced these very quick almost
knockoff style t-shirts you had the
Wagner off jewelry firm that made the
litems of Star Wars jewelry and it
doesn't stop there
Star Wars sold you underwear it's under
UN's cookies I knew it the cars and
although this may not be officially
licensed Star Wars even sold you
Japanese tuna and then you have on top
of that the roughly four billion dollars
the Star Wars made at the box office
four billion dollars for home theater
which includes VHS DVDs and then pretty
much everything else is games and books
and that includes what Disney has done
ever since it bought the Star Wars
franchise from Lucasfilm in 2012 for a
little over four billion dollars but not
every piece of merchandising worked out
for Star Wars anyone remember the Star
Wars Holiday Special
you know the quasi variety TV special
that aired on CBS just before
Thanksgiving and after the first film
was released it was chock-full of all
the things you dreamed about
Chewbacca's backstory
probably hi Princess Leia and Bea Arthur
singing a pub song at the Mos Eisley
cantina there were a number of items
that were supposed to come out after the
Star Wars Holiday Special there were
action figures based on the Wookiees
that form a big part of the holiday
special there were you know books on the
Wookiees I think a lot of that was
scaled back when it came out but now
Lucasfilm thought that was going to be
big if you look at the original scripts
for the holiday special it was going to
be a bit better than it turned out it
just ended up in the hands of a couple
of variety producers who made it way
more cheesy than it was intended flip
the story around so it was basically
unwatchable speaking of unwatchable how
about all those prequels don't they
count as failures - they're all
profitable someone went to see them
episode 1 was the one that has made the
most money in pure dollar terms yes I
just adore inflation episode 1 made more
money interestingly it made most of its
money abroad so consider the fact that
what most people hated about the
prequels was you know the stilted
dialogue the lack of good acting none of
these things can you see you know if
you're watching it internationally if
it's dubbed if it's looking at subtitles
that may sound like good luck but it
speaks to the innovation of the
franchise innovation it developed after
the first movie hit theaters back when
few people thought Star Wars would be a
hit and even fewer thought it would make
money on of all things merchandising
movie merchandising did not make money
it worked for TV franchises like Star
Trek it was not expected to work for
Star Wars and it almost didn't the
process of making toys took so long the
Kenner ended up selling cardboard
versions of their toys at Christmas time
with the promise that they would arrive
later they'll be sent to you at home
between February 1st and June 1st
the Star Wars earlybird certificate
package new from Kenner you know they
took so long to ramp up their production
that by the time the toys actually
arrived in stores supposedly we thought
Star Wars would be out of theaters of
course as it turned out it was there for
a year so then what was different about
Star Wars how did it change the movie
industry as far as merchandising goes
because it stuck around for so long it
actually meant that you can get the
merchandising to consumers while the
movie was still in the theaters which
was huge and that had not been done
before it's sort of because of the fans
it was because of the fans it was
because there was this incredible
repeatability to it and there was
accounts almost immediately there were
local entrepreneurs who came along and
made t-shirts but this was the the era
of making buttons right making buttons
at home button entrepreneurs so
immediately you may the force be with
you became a button and that was very
much I sort of you know or do you
understand this you're in you're in with
the hip crowd what about the underground
merchandising you mentioned buttons but
also people made their own costumes
people make their own fanfiction people
made things on their own because they
were fans of what was going on whether
they wanted to sell it or not and
Lucasfilm really wanted to encourage
that at the start the only part of the
the fan the traditional fan fiction side
of things that they looked askance at
was the slash fiction which is basically
fan written porn this had been huge in
the Star Trek community but otherwise
other than that they used the power of
the fans right from the beginning that
power is on full display with the r2
builder's a group of amateur droid
engineers who make their own r2d2 s and
share their work online but they tend to
spend on average I'd say about 10 years
on each r2d2 I mean it is so meticulous
they're in their garages you know honing
their metal domes and just trying to get
every detail accurate but in so doing
and in being so obsessed with that goal
and tinkering with the our 2d zoos they
became so much better than Lucasfilm at
building an r2d2 so they were actually
tapped by Kathleen Kennedy the pro
at Lucasfilm to create the r2 that will
show in the force awakens so again you
know treat your fans well and you get
this tremendous not quite unpaid labor
but you know you get a little skunk
works
what kind of Star Wars do you think
we'll expect from Disney I think Disney
is very very smart in the way that it
approaches its subsidiaries if you look
at the way it treated Pixar it was
originally owned by George Lucas still
calls it my company but Pixar was
treated like the crown jewels they could
make whatever they want to make same was
true of Marvel we almost don't think of
Marvel as a Disney subsidiary and really
the same hands-off approach has been
taken to Lucasfilm there's a very much
it ain't broke don't fix it
let the Nerds who are in charge of the
franchise stay in charge let the guys in
the story group figure out you know
we're all the bits of the universe go
you know I think episode 7 has the
distinct potential to be the
highest-grossing film of all time and I
think the interesting thing about this
is it all feeds into the other parts of
the Empire so the more of a success that
the force awakens is the more of a
success that the merchandising will be
you know you just referred to Disney as
the Empire they are I mean it's you know
but then Lucasfilm saw itself as the
Empire as well I mean Lucas would often
refer to himself as Darth Vader and the
Lucasfilm headquarters was known as the
Death Star but yes when the mouse house
moved in I mean that is a real Empire
you know no question about that